welcome to Pi data Global 2022 and in
this talk today we are going to see how
to transcribe uh audio of motivational
Sports talks using a speech to text
provider in Python
and drive insights uh from those
um Drive insights from those uh from the
from the transcript to determine which
talk is like the most motivating and
uplifting
um and hopefully there's some sports
fans here or some AI fans here as well
so let's get started
um so you may be wondering like what
inspired this talk
yes I I was an athlete yes I do python
uh but there was this movie called Rudy
uh that changed my life
um and you know back in the day back in
the 90s I've I've watched it and it's
about a young boy who has dreams of
playing American football at Notre Dame
one of the best you know the history his
history to program football programs in
the in the whole country but he was very
unathletic and he was like you know like
five feet tall not very not very tall
not very athletic uh people think he's
like it's such a wild idea of him
playing at this team but he ends up
making the team as a walk-on so like a
non-scholarship player
um there's lots of motivational uh
speeches in this movie and and so
there's a bigger reason for this talk
though that's personal to me
foreign
so every year
um uh when I was in high school I mean I
played girls basketball and every year
we would go to the state tournament
which is where all the best basketball
teams played for the championship and
I'm sorry for the quality of this photo
it was from the 1990s
so we had this Nemesis they were called
Milwaukee Washington and their team was
so good like they were stacked like all
of their starting five was just
you know like professional type players
and every year they beat us at the state
tournament
and so we figured oh God there's like no
possibility of ever beating this team
um so we just started believing that we
just can't win like we can't beat this
team
and so my senior year of high school my
coach we call him Coach K there he is
with him and I they're uh sat down he
came to our house sat down with my
parents and I and said we're doing
something different this year
um and so the first day of practice
girls basketball practice we're all like
shooting around thinking we're just
going to have a normal practice he walks
in he goes everybody to the film room so
he takes us to this classroom
and he has us watch the movie Rudy uh
and there's a scene in the movie where
uh Rudy
um who's this Underdog right uh he sacks
the quarterback he finally gets into the
game and he makes a tackle against the
quarterback and everybody's like
cheering Rudy Rudy and his teammates
carry him off the field and it's just
this very dramatic moment and every day
before practice we would watch that
scene of the movie and something started
to happen to us in our subconscious mind
and what do you think happened well
you'll find out at the end of our time
together today so my name is Tanya Sims
I'm a python developer Advocate at Deep
gram uh deep Graham we're an AI speech
to text company we transcribe streaming
uh real time and pre-recorded audio but
we're more than a transcription company
we have you know tons of features that
you can use with your transcriptions I'm
also a former professional athlete I
played professional basketball uh moved
from being an athlete to doing
pharmaceutical sales and then into Tech
uh as a developer now I'm a pythonisto
and we can connect on Twitter hopefully
Twitter is going to be around for some
time but I'm just at Tanya Sims on
Twitter feel free to tweet me during
this talk or send me a direct message as
well
so the talks that we're going to be the
sorry the sports uh motivational videos
that we're going to be transcribing
today uh are so we have a talk from a
American football player named Daryl
green who was a Hall of Famer and we're
going to transcribe his Hall of Fame
speech it's considered to be one of the
best Hall of Fame speeches ever and I
wanted to dig in a little bit deeper to
that to see why that is why people think
that Kobe Bryant talk we're going to
transcribe you know obviously I think a
lot of people knew who Kobe Bryant was a
great motivational speaker Serena
Williams the goat of tennis right the
greatest of all time just an amazing
world to win and also a motivational
talk by a very popular college
basketball coach with a big personality
named Jimmy Valvano
and so uh we're going to be doing a
pre-recorded transcription using deep
gram where you upload a file or a
hostage file online and transcribe from
speech to text we're going to tap into
some of the features like summarization
which gives a preview and summarizes
content uh topic detection extracting
key topics from text with the benefit of
quickly identifying patterns sentiment
analysis identifying the tone of a tone
of a transcript is you know positive
negative or neutral and we're also going
to be tapping into another feature
called the profanity profanity filter if
we have time which removes profanity
from a transcript so those are just a
few of our features that we have so
we're using our python SDK and which is
on GitHub you can find it to transcribe
a pre-recorded file so let's get started
so I wanted to show you like the code
for the pre-recorded transcriptions you
can see how easy it is
so the first thing you would do is just
initialize the you know deep gram SDK
with your API key
open up an audio file
then create a dictionary with audio as
buffer and mime type as appropriate in
this case we're transcribing MP3 files
and the magic kind of happens here deep
gram does the pre-recorded transcription
passing in the source and optional
features like punctuation and then we're
just printing the Json response
okay so you see how simple it is
okay so let's get into the transcription
of our Sports audio so Daryl green
you know former NF American NFL player
football player uh
I'd never heard of Daryl green honestly
uh until about 10 years ago he he's
retired you know many many years ago
before that but uh he is considered to
be one of the best defensive players
ever and he was uh inducted into the
Hall of Fame in 2008 and as I was saying
earlier his Hall of Fame speech is
considered to be one of the best ever
and I wanted to understand why that is
so deep Graham has a summarization
feature which just gives you a preview
of the transcripts think you know call
center use case customers who need to
navigate through a large number of calls
and analyze important conversations
through like generated summaries
and so here's Daryl Green's summary from
the transcript uh you know Deacon Jones
said I would cry You Bet Your Life I'm
going to cry that's my boy right there
so what I took away from this is the
there's another Hall of Famer named
Deacon Jones who played for the same
team he's older than Daryl maybe he
spoke with uh with Deacon before his
Hall of Fame speech and he knew he was
going to be very emotional
so the way to use summarization with
deep gram is very very simple you just
pass in uh summarize a true parameter
into the uh python uh dictionary here
topic detection for Daryl green speech
once again topic detection just extracts
key topics from the text with the
benefit of quickly identifying patterns
and the transcripts
and here are some of the topics for
Daryl green some of the ones that stick
out to me are parenting family and then
of course he kind of you know he gets
into like some religious things like
Christianity God Bible that type of
things leadership as well
so what I derive from this transcript of
speech is that you know this is a man
who's very religious uh and so maybe
that's why people thought this was the
best uh Hall of Fame speech ever
so for the more visual people here's
kind of a word cloud that I created in
Python and you can kind of see the
topics that stick out
topic detection once again very simple
to use in deep gram and Implement you
just pass and detect topics and set it
to true in the python dictionary
Kobe Bryant let's jump into his uh
uh his his uh his his speech you know
Kobe Bryant is in my top five of NBA
players uh
he I mean how could he not be right he
was so similar to Michael Jordan and one
of the best players to ever play the
game and just a really great
motivational speaker
so let's look into the summary for Kobe
Bryant for his uh talk
um yeah I'm not gonna read the whole
thing you can kind of see the summary
here but uh what I took from this
summary is Kobe was driven to be the
best uh you know he was always
practicing and getting better and he was
motivated to never quit as you can see
here in the summary you know he had a
purpose he wanted to be one of the best
basketball players to ever play the game
of basketball
Kobe Bryant topic detection with deep
Graham uh some of the things that stood
out to me here are you know Sports Games
sports Once Again Sports uh fitness
exercise Athletics
um Sports again comes up uh parenting
and he loved his children uh children
games so you can see he was very focused
on winning and sports uh and parenting
on his children so that's when I derived
from the topic detection for Kobe Bryant
so for those more visual here's a word
cloud you can kind of see what sticks
out here you know sports games parenting
that those types of topics
so that's moving to Serena Williams
speech you know I'll never forget the
first time hearing about Serena and
Venus Williams you know amazing tennis
players I was visiting my grandparents
in Kentucky and my grandmother showed me
a Sports Illustrated magazine with
Serena and Venus on the cover and it was
like the most amazing thing that I've
ever seen and inspired me in my own
sports career
so the summary for Serena Williams from
her speech Her speech called I believe
uh you know she says I always wanted to
be the best when I go out there I really
have to shut down my mind I have to say
to myself you know what I'm just playing
a great player and I'm not gonna read
the thing but as you can see Serena
Williams hates to lose and she has such
a will to win and that's why she's the
greatest of all time
topic detection for Serena Williams
so these are some of the topics that
stuck out to me you know that that sorry
these are some of the topics that uh
were derived uh from our topic detection
Games sports uh Gods uh and um my
takeaway from this is you know she comes
from a very religious family
uh and then there's also a war there uh
so she did not say war in Her speech but
maybe she talked about like the fierce
competition because many people compare
war or battle to sports
but this is from her speech I believe
where she talks about that anybody you
know you can achieve anything you want
uh in life if you believe in yourself
for the more visual people here is the
word cloud I think it's pretty evenly
distributed but we'll get into the
sentiment analysis in a bit and you
you'll see kind of how things shift a
little bit
okay and let's talk about Jimmy Valvano
so Jimmy Valvano was a very popular
college coach at North Carolina State
big personality I mean just a lovable
guy his players absolutely adored him
I'll never forget watching his speech
um the speech of Jimmy at the ESPYs
which is a award show for sports people
and the theme of his speech was never
give up it was so emotional okay because
he was fighting of his battle with
cancer at the time and you know
unfortunately he did lose his battle
with cancer a few months after the
speech and it was just a huge loss for
the college basketball community
so let's talk about the summary from
that Jimmy Valvano speech
you know he's he says you know I'm
here's a summary uh he's a he's I'm very
emotional passionate man being the son
of Ron Angelina balvano it comes with
the territory
um and then he goes on to say something
like you know um I don't know much time
I have left and I have some things that
I would like to say if you laugh and you
think and you think and you cry you're
gonna do that seven days a week so what
I took away from the summary is Jimmy
Valvano obviously very passionate
emotional speech and he's not sure how
much time he has left on Earth
topic detection for Jimmy Valvano
let's look at some of the topics that
came from the speech uh you know you
know unfortunately you know cancerous
one love relationships Sports uh death
diseases uh Sports and speech and
cancer is you know so as we can see you
know cancer was definitely at the top of
his mind rightfully so this was a man
who was battling uh this disease uh and
so that's you know kind of what his
speech was kind of centered around
um and uh once again the word caught as
you can see you know the topics that
really um stick stuck out from that
speech
so let's uh talk about sentiment
analysis which um you know I sent up an
analysis identifies the emotional tone
behind a body of tax and determines
whether it's
positive neutral or negative positive
being you know your attitude toward a
particular topic is good neutral being
attitude towards a particular topic is
okay okay uh and negative you attitude
towards a particular particular topic is
bad
so once again uh deep Graham we uh you
know have a sentiment feature uh we're
using our python SDK again very simple
you see how it is to implement sentiment
analysis in the code you just pass in uh
sentiment as a python key dictionary key
and give it a value of true
um
and with sentiment analysis it adds
punctuation by default and um you know
when you run the code and all the
features that I've showed you today with
even
um uh summarization topic detection
it'll give you a Json response with the
objects that you're looking for
okay so let's talk about the sentiment
for the speeches that we reviewed
already Daryl green you know just
through recap you know NFL Hall of Fame
Fame speech former American football
player his speech was centered around
religion and God
so
um
so what I did here uh I'm not going to
show the code for this because of time
constraint but what I did is this I um
did some parsing you know I received the
Json response back when I passed in that
sentiment true parameter parsed it did
some aggregation and used pandas for the
grouping and so for Daryl green you can
see negative uh 10 negative instances of
sentiment uh neutral 47 and then 21
positive from his speech then I used the
matplot lib which is a python library to
graph the average percent of the
sentiment so as you can see here
um let me just make it a little bigger
as you can see here uh neutral 58.2
percent negative 13 and positive around
27. uh percent positive for his speech
uh Kobe Bryant his speech about wanting
to be the best basketball player ever
speech sentiment so in his speech uh
roughly you know
61 uh maybe instances of negative speech
159 instances of mutual speech 54
um 54 instances of positive speech in
one instance a very positive speech in
the transcript
and so here's a graph that I created
from that plot live you can see here 56
percent neutral for his speech uh 22
negative uh 20 of his speech was
positive and about point four percent of
Kobe Bryant's speech was very positive
the sentiment for Serena Williams it
just says you know recap her I believe
in you I believe in yourself speech that
she gave uh the aggregation
um 11 instances of negative speech 18
instances of neutral speech and 23
instances of positive speech for the
sentiment
and her graph uh as you can see hers is
the most positive so far uh with 44
positive 31 neutral and 24 negative
and last but not least we have Jimmy
Valvano uh recall his you know very
passion and emotional speech about never
giving up as he was uh succumbing to
cancer at the ESPYs uh where he gave
that speech
uh 31 instances of negative speech for
the sentence for the sentiment for his
uh transcript 100 instances of neutral
speech 52 instances of positive speech
and one instance of a very positive
speech and what does this graph look
like
um 54 of his speech was neutral
about 28 of a speech was positive 0.5
percent of his speech was very positive
and 17 of his speech was negative so as
you can tell like based on sentiment
like if we're going to say based on
sentiment
which speech was the most positive
it was Serena Williams If you recall Her
speech was about 44
44.4 positive so she had the most
positive sentiment so she's the winner
so let's take a look really quickly
because we only have a few minutes left
at another feature which I think is kind
of applies to the situation is uh we
have a profanity filter uh feature which
um filters out profanity by converting
it converting it to the nearest
recognized like non-profane word or
remove it completely from the transcript
so what I did is I took a transcript of
so I transcribed uh a speech by a
football coach a college American
football coach called buddy Stevens and
he curses a lot and he was giving the
speech at halftime to his players uh and
this documentary it's called last chance
you on Netflix if you want to check it
out it's about a two-year college junior
college in Mississippi and he just used
a lot of profanity when he talks and so
after transcribe sorry before
transcribing Coach Stevens uh
uh talk like this is you know
um we're actually sorry sorry let me let
me just retract a little bit so this is
transcribing his speech but without our
profanity filter and so this is what it
looks like and I kind of blank out the
curse words so you can imagine you know
what that
um how that sound I'm not going to read
it because I don't want to be respectful
in case people don't curse or anything
but you can see where all the blinks are
that's where all the profanity words
were
so if you want to uh use the profanity
filter and filter out the profanity once
again very simple you just pass in a
profanity filter parameter and set it to
true and it will give you a Json
response with the transcript without the
profanity
and so let's take a look at the
transcript what that looks like without
profanity
look at this there there are no more
curse words uh it's pretty uh pretty
cool I think
um so yeah you can see that all the
cursors are gone
um so I think it's very uh this is a
very useful feature if you know maybe if
you're uh you know if kids have to see
this or
um you're in a professional setting
where you don't want the curse words or
the profanity to be shown
so
coming circling back to the beginning of
this talk uh you know I was talking
about our Nemesis uh in high school when
I was in high school Milwaukee
Washington the girls basketball team
always beat us at state
we could never win against them we just
thought that oh wow like we just we can
never beat this team
in our Heist my high school coach had us
watch the movie Rudy
um and uh you know which was about this
uh
football player who people think he
could never make it at the Collegiate
level and he ends up you know walking
onto the team and becoming this hero
um and our subconscious Minds start to
shift because we you know our coach had
us watch that scene every day before
practice and we started believing in
ourselves
and guess what happened we finally beat
our Nemesis for the girls basketball
state championship and not only did we
beat them we like crush them by 20
points uh yeah so it was it was really
cool just a great moment
um so for most of us motivational
speeches you know help Inspire Us in all
Fields Not Just Sports
so if you would like to try deep gram
our speech to text API or or our python
SDK
you can just go to console.deepgram.com
or you can take a screenshot sorry uh
you know screenshot or take a picture of
the QR code it'll take you directly to
the console we give you a hundred fifty
dollars of free credit for transcription
which is very generous you can try our
real-time streaming and our pre-recorded
transcription from the browser so I want
to thank you for your time today and I
want to send a special thank you to Pi
data Global
um if you have any questions uh in
particular about getting started with
deep gram sports or our parts on SDK
feel free to ask thank you so much